Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The year is 48 BC. Your name is Bayek of Siwa, Medjai of Egypt, protector of the weak and defender of the innocent. And you have a job to do. Your mission is to meet your wife, Aya, an agent of the exiled Cleopatra,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。时间是公元前48年。你的名字是锡瓦的巴耶克（Bayek of Siwa），埃及守护者（Medjai），弱者的保护者，无辜者的捍卫者。你有一项任务要完成。你的使命是去见你的妻子艾雅（Aya），她是流亡的克利奥帕特拉（Cleopatra）的一名特工，
in perhaps the most celebrated building in all Alexandria, the Great Library. And as you step inside, the sheer spectacle takes your breath away. The marble pillars, the stone statues and mosaic floors, the vast effigy of the god Serapis, the Greek scholars huddled at their desks, and above all, the bookcases, lined with more than half a million scrolls and parchments. Here, before your awestruck eyes, is the learning of the entire ancient world, with a copy of every book ever written, from Aristotle and Aristophanes to Homer and Herodotus. And above the shelves in Greek is an inscription. For this, it says, is the place that will cure your soul. And that, Tom Holland, is your first
在亚历山大城最著名的建筑——大图书馆中。当你走进去时，那壮观的景象让你屏住了呼吸。大理石柱、石像和马赛克地板，巨大的塞拉皮斯神（Serapis）雕像，蜷缩在书桌旁的希腊学者，最重要的是，那些书架上摆放着超过五十万卷的卷轴和羊皮纸。在这里，在你惊叹的目光前，是整个古代世界的学问，每一本写过的书都有副本，从亚里士多德（Aristotle）和阿里斯托芬（Aristophanes）到荷马（Homer）和希罗多德（Herodotus）。在书架上方，用希腊文刻着一行铭文。它写道，这里是治愈灵魂的地方。汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），这就是你第一次
sight of the great library of Alexandria in the video game Assassin's Creed Origins. Now, Tom, they got historians to help them develop the game. And to be fair, this is the image of the library that you will find in most books about the life of Cleopatra and the age of the Ptolemies, isn't it? It is. But I think that Assassin's Creed deals with myth and archetype as well as hardcore historical research, doesn't it? You astound me, Tom. I think that the great library, the great library Library of Alexandria is most potent as a myth. In a way,
在电子游戏《刺客信条：起源》（Assassin's Creed Origins）中看到亚历山大图书馆的景象。汤姆，他们请了历史学家来协助开发这款游戏。平心而论，这就是你在大多数关于克利奥帕特拉生平和托勒密时代（Age of the Ptolemies）的书籍中看到的图书馆形象，对吧？确实如此。但我认为《刺客信条》不仅涉及硬核历史研究，还涉及神话和原型，不是吗？你让我感到惊讶，汤姆。我认为大图书馆，亚历山大图书馆作为一种神话最为强大。在某种程度上，
the fact that it hasn't survived, that no trace of its remains exists, that all its texts have vanished, and we'll be talking about how and why they might have vanished later in the show. I think it's that that enables it to endure in the imagination as a kind of embodiment of ultimate learning, repository of everything, every book that has ever been compiled. I think it feeds into all kinds of fantasy. There's a wonderful short story by Jorge Luis Borges, the great Argentinian short story writer. I wondered if we'd talk about that.
它没有留存下来，没有任何遗迹存在，所有的文本都消失了，我们稍后会在节目中讨论它们是如何以及为何消失的。我认为正是这一点使它在想象中得以永存，成为终极学问的化身，是所有知识、每一本被编纂过的书的宝库。我认为它滋养了各种各样的幻想。豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯（Jorge Luis Borges），那位伟大的阿根廷短篇小说家，写过一篇精彩的短篇小说。我一直在想我们是否会谈到它。
The Library of Babel, which contains not just every book that's ever been written, but every possible book that might be written, every conceivable permutation. And the whole universe has become a library. And I think that that kind of fantasy ultimately derives from this kind of the mythic quality that the Library of Alexandria has come to have. Do you think? Oh, wonderful. Yeah, I think that's a really good way of putting it.
《巴别图书馆》（The Library of Babel），它不仅包含了有史以来写过的每一本书，还包含了每一本可能写出的书，每一个可以想象到的排列组合。整个宇宙变成了一个图书馆。我认为这种幻想最终源于亚历山大图书馆所具有的这种神话特质。你觉得呢？哦，太棒了。是的，我认为这是一个非常好的表达方式。
And of course, Borges' library is kind of one of the models, isn't it, for the library in The Name of the Rose? Yes. So isn't that based on Borges' library? So actually the idea of the Library of Alexandria, I mean, it's a classic thing in science fiction, actually. You get it in Doctor Who and things, these images of kind of vast libraries spreading,
当然，博尔赫斯的图书馆是《玫瑰的名字》（The Name of the Rose）中图书馆的原型之一，不是吗？是的。那它不是基于博尔赫斯的图书馆吗？实际上，亚历山大图书馆的概念，在科幻小说中是一个经典主题。你在《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）之类的作品中也能看到，这些巨大的图书馆蔓延开来，
taking entire planets in which all the knowledge of the world, I suppose, to some extent you could say the internet, isn't it? Or the ambition of Wikipedia or something. I mean, these things are... Or Dominic, actually the dream that emerged in the enlightenment of developing a universal library. So I wanted to do this episode because I'm a trustee of the British Library, which I was very proud. I looked up to see what the world's largest libraries were and British Library is listed number one, just ahead of the Library of Congress. Oh, that's very gratifying, Tom. And the British Library was set up 50 years ago, but it draws on, of course,
占据了整个星球，里面拥有世界上的所有知识。我想在某种程度上，你可以说这就是互联网，对吧？或者是维基百科（Wikipedia）的雄心壮志之类的。我的意思是，这些东西是……或者多米尼克，实际上是启蒙运动中出现的建立通用图书馆的梦想。所以我做这一期节目是因为我是大英图书馆（British Library）的受托人，我对此感到非常自豪。我查了一下世界上最大的图书馆有哪些，大英图书馆名列第一，领先于国会图书馆（Library of Congress）。哦，那真是太令人欣慰了，汤姆。大英图书馆成立于50年前，但它当然借鉴了
collections in the British Museum and then before that, other private collections. And it is in a way, an embodiment of that dream that we associate with the Library of Alexandria, essentially to be universal in the scale of learning that it offers. So it offers 170 million different items printed, digital archives of books and manuscripts and journals and everything, works of art, patents. And it has objects that are thousands of years old. It has tweets that were sent out a few hours earlier. I think that libraries like the British Library, Library of Congress, Bibliothèque Nationale in Paris, and so on, that these also
大英博物馆（British Museum）的藏品，以及在此之前的其他私人收藏。在某种程度上，它是我们与亚历山大图书馆联系在一起的那个梦想的化身，本质上是要在它所提供的学问规模上实现通用。它提供了1.7亿件不同的物品，包括印刷品、书籍和手稿的数字档案、期刊以及各种艺术作品、专利。它有几千年前的文物，也有几个小时前发布的推文。我认为像大英图书馆、国会图书馆、巴黎的法国国家图书馆（Bibliothèque Nationale）等等，这些也
stand in a line of descent from the Library of Alexandria. I think it is that fantasy that came to obsess people in Europe in the Renaissance and then through to the Enlightenment that kind of explains the existence of these universal libraries, wouldn't you say? Yeah, I think that's nice. First of all, I think the British Library Press Office will be delighted with that, Tom. So I hope all sorts of rewards will be flowing your way. Well, I'm very, very honoured to be a trustee of this great library. Yeah, it's so unlike you actually to be talking about your own your own honors on this podcast it's never happened before um but yeah i guess the idea of the national library and the idea of a single repository of learning that contains all
与亚历山大图书馆有着传承关系。我认为正是那种在欧洲文艺复兴时期，随后通过启蒙运动让人着迷的幻想，解释了这些通用图书馆的存在，你觉得呢？是的，我觉得很好。首先，我认为大英图书馆的新闻办公室会对此感到高兴的，汤姆。所以我希望各种奖励会向你涌来。嗯，我非常非常荣幸能成为这个伟大图书馆的受托人。是的，在播客上谈论你自己的荣誉真是太不像你了，这以前从未发生过。嗯，但我想国家图书馆的概念，以及包含所有知识的单一知识库的概念，
learning that that is a sort of i mean most nations have national libraries don't they and i suppose all of these things derive ultimately from this idea of this platonic ideal of a library, ironically, given that it must have had the works of Plato. Yes, absolutely. But of course, that then raises the question of where did the people who founded the Library of Alexandria, where did they get their idea from? Is the idea of constructing libraries as old as civilization. In one sense, it does seem to be. I think that the moment that writing is developed, the instinct to collect texts and assemble them in one place does seem to have been pretty universal. In Egypt, where they manufacture papyrus, which is the writing material in which the scrolls in the Library of Alexandria are kept, the priests seem to have used temples as repositories for scrolls that are connected with
那是一种……我的意思是，大多数国家都有国家图书馆，不是吗？我想所有这些东西最终都源于这种柏顿式的图书馆理想，讽刺的是，考虑到它一定收藏了柏拉图（Plato）的作品。是的，绝对是。但这当然引出了一个问题：那些建立亚历山大图书馆的人，他们的想法是从哪里来的？建立图书馆的想法是否和文明一样古老？在某种意义上，似乎确实如此。我认为文字一旦发展出来，收集文本并将它们汇集在一个地方的本能似乎就相当普遍了。在埃及，他们制造莎草纸，这是亚历山大图书馆卷轴所用的书写材料，祭司们似乎利用神庙作为与
the specific cult. None of them have survived because Papyrus disintegrates. But in the Near East, they use clay. If clay gets fired, then it remains almost undestroyable. So archaeologists, when they dig up these ancient cities across the Near East, have every so often found these incredible depositories of vast numbers of clay tablets. I think the oldest is a place called Ebla, which is about 30 miles southwest of Aleppo in Syria, which dates back to 2300 BC. There's the great capital of the Hittite Empire, which is 17th to 13th centuries BC. I mean, huge amounts of texts there, absolutely invaluable for informing us not just about the Hittite Empire, but about the Near East more generally. Assyrians seem to,
特定崇拜相关的卷轴的存放处。它们都没有留存下来，因为莎草纸会分解。但在近东，他们使用粘土。如果粘土经过烧制，它几乎是不可摧毁的。因此，考古学家在挖掘近东各地的这些古城时，不时会发现这些令人难以置信的、藏有大量泥板的仓库。我认为最古老的是一个叫埃勃拉（Ebla）的地方，位于叙利亚阿勒颇（Aleppo）西南约30英里处，其历史可以追溯到公元前2300年。还有赫梯帝国（Hittite Empire）的伟大首都，那是公元前17至13世纪。我的意思是，那里有大量的文本，对于了解赫梯帝国以及更广泛的近东地区来说，绝对是无价之宝。亚述人似乎，
you know, they're famous as a militaristic imperial people, very prone to wiping out cities, but they seem to have adored libraries. So actually the oldest library whose founder we know was founded in 1100 BC by an Assyrian king with the splendid name of Tiglath Pelesa. That is a good name. I always thought it would make a great name for a cat actually. Yeah. Or a beer, an Indonesian beer. The mellow hops of a Tiglath Pelesa. But the most famous Assyrian library is the one founded by Ashurbanipal. There was a wonderful exhibition about Ashurbanipal in the British Museum a couple of years ago. And Ashurbanipal, who was notorious among his subject peoples for his oppressive militarism,
你知道，他们以好战的帝国民族而闻名，非常倾向于消灭城市，但他们似乎非常热爱图书馆。所以实际上，我们所知其创始人最古老的图书馆是由一位亚述国王在公元前1100年建立的，他有着一个响亮的名字：提格拉特帕拉沙尔（Tiglath Pileser）。那是个好名字。我一直认为这会是一个猫的好名字。是的。或者是一种啤酒，一种印尼啤酒。提格拉特帕拉沙尔的醇厚啤酒花。但最著名的亚述图书馆是由亚述巴尼拔（Ashurbanipal）建立的。几年前大英博物馆有一个关于亚述巴尼拔的精彩展览。亚述巴尼拔，他在他的臣民中以其压迫性的军国主义而臭名昭著，
he's shown with a kind of pen tucked into his belt as an emblem of his ability to read and write. And so there were kind of 30,000 clay tablets in that. Most of them were, they were kind of prophetic writings, omens, spells for warding off evil spirits, that kind of thing. But there were a few kind of classic literary texts of which Gilgamesh is the most famous. The oldest epic. Yes. So, I mean, an incredibly important archive. And that seems to have had a cataloging system,
他被描绘成腰间插着一支笔，作为他读写能力的象征。那里大约有30,000块泥板。其中大多数是预言性的著作、预兆、驱邪的咒语之类的东西。但也有一些经典的文学文本，其中《吉尔伽美什》（Gilgamesh）是最著名的。最古老的史诗。是的。所以，这是一个极其重要的档案。而且它似乎有一套编目系统，
and it seems to have had librarians who get stressed out about books being stolen. So, there are all these kind of warnings saying, you know, if you steal one, then the spirits will come and get you. May Nabu decree his destruction is my favorite. Brilliant. I think all libraries should still have that. So, Tom, on these libraries, isn't there an argument that civilization, which is obviously identified with kind of urbanism, that part of that is the control? I mean, you have a monopoly of violence. That's one of the elements of having a state, but also a monopoly of information, control of information, of records, of laws, of regulations and codes, of property ownership. And to have all that, you actually need a library of some description, don't you? You need a place, a single repository where all the stuff is stored, where the king can
而且似乎有图书管理员因为书籍被盗而感到压力。所以，有各种各样的警告说，你知道，如果你偷了一本，那么灵魂就会来找你。我最喜欢的是“愿纳布（Nabu）下令毁灭他”。太棒了。我认为所有的图书馆都应该保留这一点。那么，汤姆，关于这些图书馆，难道没有一种观点认为文明——显然与城市化有关——其部分内容就是控制吗？我的意思是，你拥有暴力的垄断权。这是拥有国家要素之一，但也有信息的垄断权，对记录、法律、法规和准则、财产所有权的控制。要拥有这一切，你实际上需要某种形式的图书馆，不是吗？你需要一个地方，一个单一的知识库，所有东西都存储在那里，国王可以
go or the emperor can go and say, I want to find out what did we do last time? What are the laws on this? I mean, it has to be written down somewhere. Yes. And so a lot of these libraries, so the text found at Persepolis as well, which gets burnt by Alexander, these are to do with the administration of the empire very often. The library of Ashurbanipal seems to have been definitely set up by the king himself. He has a personal stake in it. But this seems to be because the king has a responsibility to the dimension of the
去那里说，我想查查我们上次是怎么做的？关于这个的法律是什么？我的意思是，它必须写在某个地方。是的。所以很多这些图书馆，比如在波斯波利斯（Persepolis）发现的文本——后来被亚历山大烧毁了——这些通常与帝国的行政管理有关。亚述巴尼拔的图书馆似乎确实是由国王本人建立的。他个人对此有投入。但这似乎是因为国王对超自然维度负有责任，所以他雇佣了各种各样的人来预测未来，为国王和帝国驱除邪恶。而这基本上，我认为，就是他的图书馆的全部意义所在。它是为占卜者、预言家准备的参考图书馆。所以即使是史诗也可能在那里，因为它们具有某种占卜作用。所以它并不完全像我们在现代世界中梦想的通用图书馆。而且，我认为它也与埃及国王在亚历山大城建立图书馆的雄心壮志有着微妙的不同。我认为要真正理解这些雄心壮志，以及亚历山大图书馆似乎与
supernatural, so he's employing all kinds of people who can forecast the future, ward off evils from both the king and the empire. And that is basically, I think, what his library is all about. It's a kind of reference library for diviners, for soothsayers. So even the epics are probably there because they have kind of divinatory roles. So it's not quite like the dream of the universal library that we have in the modern world. And it's also, I think, kind of subtly different from the ambitions that the kings of Egypt who found the library in Alexandria have. And I think to properly get a handle on what those ambitions are and the way in which the Library of Alexandria does seem to have been something quite different from the libraries of
之前的近东图书馆有何不同，你需要将其置于背景中。因为实际上，像图书馆这样的文化产物是那些认为它们值得建立和维护的文化的表达。是的，我完全同意你的看法，汤姆。这是否给了我们一个谈论亚历山大大帝（Alexander the Great）的机会，他是《历史的余味》的伟大创始人？我想是的。是的。哦，太棒了，太棒了。
the Near East that preceded them, you need to put it in context. Because actually, cultural artefacts like libraries are expressions of the culture that think that they are worth founding and maintaining. Yeah, I couldn't agree with you more, Tom. And does this give us an opportunity to talk about Alexander the Great, great founder of the rest of his history? I think it does. Yeah. Oh, wonderful. Wonderful.
所以如果你以为这全是关于一堆无聊的旧书，那你就大错特错了，因为我们现在要谈论的是世界上最伟大的征服者之一，也是新一代男孩和女孩的灵感来源，多亏了《时间冒险》（Adventures in Time）系列。是的。你非常、非常有启发性。你关于亚历山大大帝的书的结尾非常有启发性，鼓励孩子们走出去征服世界。
So if you thought this was all going to be about a load of boring old books, you're greatly mistaken because we're now going to be talking about one of the world's great conquerors and an inspiration, Tom, to a new generation of boys and girls, thanks to the Adventures in Time series. Yeah. You're very, very inspirational. You're a very inspirational ending of your book on Alexander the Great, encouraging children to go out there and conquer the world.
我们内心都有一个亚历山大。是的。那么告诉我们关于亚历山大城的事。我喜欢亚历山大城。在《历史的余味》中，我们经常被问到，你最想回到哪里？我喜欢亚历山大城，因为它是一个融合之地。它部分是希腊的，部分是埃及的。它部分是埃及的。
We all have an inner Alexander. Yeah. So tell us about Alexandria. I love Alexandria. We're often asked on The Rest is History, where would you most like to go back to? And I love Alexandria as this syncretic place. It's partly Greek. It's partly Egyptian. It's partly Egyptian.
它是由亚历山大本人建立的，不是吗？我的意思是，至少传说如此。我不认为这是传说。我的意思是，我认为他几乎是从零开始建立的。他需要一个港口，不是吗？他需要在北非海岸有一个不属于旧祭司精英阶层的港口。这是在公元前331年。他已经征服了大部分近东地区。
It's founded by Alexander himself, isn't it? I mean, that's the legend, at least. I don't think it's a legend. I mean, I think he does found it pretty much from scratch. He needs a harbour, doesn't he? He needs a harbour on the North African coast that's not part of the old priestly elite. This is in 331 BC. He's conquered most of the Near East.
他征服了埃及。他在埃及的古都孟菲斯（Memphis）被加冕为法老。但他想要一个能从海岸控制埃及，并显然能与地中海世界建立航运联系的城市。他选择了这个地点。这是地中海和马里奥蒂斯湖（Lake Mariotis）之间的一条狭窄陆地。它提供了一个巨大的深水港口群。这就是他选择它的关键原因。而且，你还有从湖面和海面吹来的风。
He's conquered Egypt. He's been crowned in Memphis, which is the ancient capital of Egypt, as pharaoh. But he wants a city that can control Egypt from the coast and obviously have shipping links to the Mediterranean world beyond. He chooses this site. It's a narrow bar of land between the Mediterranean Sea and a lake called Mariotis. And it provides a great complex of deep water harbours. And that's the key reason that he chooses it. It's also, you've got the winds blowing in off both the lake and the sea.
所以夏天很凉爽。这是一个极其令人眼花缭乱的人造景观。有一种像纽约那样的网格系统，全是亚历山大亲自规划的。亚历山大死后，它被他的童年好友兼副手托勒密（Ptolemy）占有，他抢走了亚历山大的遗体，带到亚历山大城并埋葬在那里。所以亚历山大的陵墓是托勒密声称自己是这位伟大征服者真正继承人的标志。那里还有其他奇迹。有法罗斯灯塔（Pharos），这座巨大的灯塔建在一个岛上。它通过一条堤道与亚历山大所在的陆地相连。
So in the summer, it's pretty cool. And it is a landscape of absolutely dazzling artificiality. So there's a kind of grid system of the kind that you get in New York, all laid out personally by Alexander. And after Alexander's death, it gets appropriated by his childhood friend and lieutenant Ptolemy, who grabs Alexander's body, brings it to Alexandria, buries it there. So the tomb of Alexander is a kind of marker of Ptolemy's claim to be the true successor of the great conqueror. There are other wonders there. There's the Pharos, this great lighthouse built on an island. It's kind of joined to the mainland where Alexander is by a mole.
这是希腊人建造的最大的建筑。它是第一个拥有编号地址的城市，我认为这是一个非常美妙的细节。它有自动售货机。它有自动门。它有国际银行。自动门是一个非常美妙的细节。它有自动售货机，它有自动门，它有国际银行。自动门，我喜欢那个细节。所以这是一个不可思议的地方。这是一个奇迹之地，在某种意义上，这些奇迹的建造部分是因为托勒密试图建立他那非常暴发户的政权，作为埃及法老伟大传统和亚历山大征服的伟大帝国的继承者。但也因为作为一个暴发户城市，它需要吸引人们，并且需要拥有人们想要来看的东西。
And this is the largest building ever built by the Greeks. It's the first city to have numbered addresses, which I think is kind of wonderful detail. It had slot machines. It had automatic doors. It had international banks. Automatic doors is kind of wonderful detail. It had slot machines, it had automatic doors, it had international banks. Automatic doors, I love that detail. So it's an incredible place. It's a place of wonders, and the wonders, in a sense, have to be built partly because Ptolemy is trying to establish his very parvenu regime as the inheritor both of the pharaonic greatness of Egypt and of the great empire conquered by Alexander. But also because as an upstart city, it needs to attract people and it needs to have things that people want to come and see.
所以它有点像迪拜或类似的地方。我正要说它就像迪拜，或者它有点像拉斯维加斯，所以这一切都很……但因为它持续了几个世纪，所以在那一点上它并不完全是……我的意思是，它是它自己的东西，但它也带有一点像巴西利亚（Brasilia）或其他地方那种规划首都的气息，不是吗？是的，你知道，他们建立了一个新的地点。他们请顶级建筑师来建造所有这些奇妙的建筑。实际上，我知道对某些人来说，我们从一个电子游戏开始听起来很傻，但那个电子游戏是以亚历山大城为背景的。
So it's a little bit, I like kind of dubai or somewhere like that i was i was about to say it's like a dubai or it's like um it's got a little bit of las vegas about it so it's all quite as that's but because it you know it lasts for centuries so at that point it's not really as that's i mean it's his own thing but it's also got the slight air of one of those planned capitals like brazilia or somewhere hasn't it yes you know they've established a new site. They get top architects to come in and build all these fantastic buildings. Actually, I know it sounds silly to some people that we started with a video game, but that video game is set in Alexandria.
而且它确实提供了——我的意思是，很多考古学家参与了它的工作。如果你玩过这个游戏，它确实让你对城市的布局、那种纯粹的奇观和宏伟感有了美妙的认识。而且它处于这种沙漠景观或沙漠边缘的灌木丛景观中。这是一个非凡的，我的意思是，它就像拉斯维加斯式的海市蜃楼。是迪拜有卢浮宫的分馆，沙特人买了达芬奇（Leonardo）的画，对吧？所以有一种感觉，通过投资文化，你正在提升你城市的声望。这非常、非常托勒密。所以托勒密人所做的一切都是关于促进贸易，提升亚历山大城作为伟大贸易之都的理念，因为那会增加财政收入。他们还有来自埃及的钱。他们有从
And it does give, I mean, lots of archaeologists worked on it. And it does give, if you ever played the game, it gives you a wonderful sense of the layout of the city, the sheer spectacle and the grandeur of it. And the fact that it's in this kind of desert landscape or the scrubby landscape at the edge of the desert, I suppose. And it's an extraordinary, I mean, it's like a Las Vegas like mirage. Is it Dubai that has the extension of the Louvre and the Saudis bought the Leonardo, didn't they? So there's this sense that by investing in culture, you are boosting the prestige of your city. And that is very, very Ptolemaic. So the Ptolemies are all about kind of boosting trade, boosting the idea of Alexandria as a great trading capital, because that then raises finance. They also have the money from Egypt. They have the loot that
外国征服中获得的战利品。所以有很多钱在流通。就像海湾地区的石油酋长一样，托勒密有能力消费。像石油酋长一样，他认识到文化是可以提升他声望的东西。这在希腊世界的独裁者中是一种传统。庇西特拉图（Peisistratus），在民主制度建立之前的雅典僭主，他赞助了戏剧节，这些戏剧节最终造就了雅典黄金时代的伟大悲剧作家和喜剧作家。他还赞助了荷马作品的标准版本。马其顿的国王们同样非常清楚他们被雅典人和古典希腊的其他民族所看不起。因此，他们非常热衷于邀请知识界的杰出人物到他们的宫廷。其中一位马其顿国王邀请了伟大的雅典悲剧作家欧里庇得斯（Euripides）去和他住在一起。亚历山大的父亲腓力（Philip）本人，著名地雇佣了那个时代最伟大的哲学家亚里士多德。托勒密在很大程度上是这一传统的继承者，但正是因为他现在是在全球范围内思考。他曾与亚历山大并肩作战。他看到了地球的极限，但似乎他的雄心远不止于仅仅雇佣一两个剧作家或哲学家。他想要更多。他想要金钱能买到的最伟大的文本和哲学家的集合。
they get from kind of foreign conquest. So there's a lot of money going around. And just like the oil shakes in the Gulf, Ptolemy is in of money going around. Just like the oil shakes in the Gulf, Ptolemy is in a position to spend. Like the oil shakes, he recognizes that culture is something that can boost his prestige. This is a kind of tradition in the Greek world for autocrats. Peisistratus, who was the tyrant in Athens before the establishment of the democracy, he sponsors the drama festivals that will culminate in the great tragedians and comedians of the Athenian golden age. And he sponsors a kind of standard edition of Homer. Kings of Macedon, likewise, they're very conscious that they look
顺便说一句，关于托勒密，值得一提的是，他是一个聪明人。他写了一本关于他与亚历山大在一起时光的回忆录，不是吗？我的意思是，他是一个有文化、精明、聪明的人。所以，也许这不仅仅是……你不必对此持怀疑态度。我的意思是，也许他可能真的喜欢学术和学问以及所有这些东西，你不觉得吗？我不认为他会看到两者之间有任何冲突。我的意思是，他不认为推广他自己的品牌和他自己的城市有什么需要道歉的。我的意思是，他完全支持这一点。但我认为他确实真诚地相信这种为学问而学问的激进概念。这就是他与亚述巴尼拔的区别所在。我认为亚述巴尼拔的图书馆完全是为了预见未来、解读凶兆等等。我
down on by the Athenians and the other peoples of classical Greece. And so they are very keen on inviting intellectual luminaries to their court. One of the Macedonian kings invites Euripides, the great Athenian tragedian, to go and stay with him. Philip himself, the father of Alexander, famously employs Aristotle, the greatest philosopher of his age. Ptolemy is very much the heir to this, but it's precisely because he is now thinking on a global scale. He has ridden with Alexander. He has seen the limits of the earth, but it seems his ambitions are much greater than simply to employ a playwright or a philosopher or two. He wants much more than that. He wants the greatest conglomeration of texts and philosophers that money can buy him.
认为对于托勒密来说，这在某种意义上是为了保存希腊文化中最精华的部分。嗯，而且他本人也受过亚里士多德的教育，因为那就是他和亚历山大相遇的地方。他们在那个树林里一起学习，亚里士多德在那里聚集了宫廷里的所有年轻人。所以绝对的，他一定受到了和亚历山大一样的影响。嗯，不，但我认为你提到亚里士多德绝对是正确的，因为我实际上认为亚里士多德——正如你所说，他教过托勒密——是其中的一个关键人物。因为亚里士多德在马其顿完成教学后，回到雅典，定居在阿波罗神庙，即吕克昂（Lyceum）。这作为一个哲学家交谈的地方是相当出名的。苏格拉底（Socrates）去过那里，柏拉图也去过那里。但亚里士多德发现了一些更持久、更雄心勃勃的东西。所以它基本上是一个研究中心，类似那样的东西。他需要一个研究中心的原因是他致力于这样一个理念：要热爱智慧——这是哲学家按定义所做的——你必须训练头脑掌握那些能让你接触到支配宇宙规律的技能。而你只能在整个生命过程中做到这一点。因此，需要一个集中的机会让哲学家们思考、阅读、研究、写作并与同行交流，否则他们将无法
It's worth saying about Ptolemy, by the way, he's a clever man. He writes a memoir, doesn't he, of his time with Alexander. I mean, he is a literate, shrewd, intelligent man. So there is part, maybe it's not just, you don't have to be cynical about it. I mean, maybe he probably really does like the idea of scholarship and learning and all these things, don't you think? I don't think that he would see any tension between it. I mean, he doesn't see that promoting his own brand and his own city is anything to apologize for. I mean, he's all in favor of that. But I think he genuinely does believe in this kind of radical concept of learning for its own sake. That's what differentiates him, say, from Ashurbanipal. I think Ashurbanipal's library is all about the ability to look into the future, to read bad omens and so on. I
充分地领悟宇宙的运行机制。所以柏拉图——我们在亚特兰蒂斯（Atlantis）的背景下谈论过他——柏拉图的伟大理论是，如果你想辨别现实，现实存在于……你知道，有一个理想的桌子。所以如果你想知道桌子的本质，那就是你必须接触的东西，而不是对现存的每一张桌子进行调查。亚里士多德有不同的视角。他认为你确实需要对整个世界有一个整体的认识。他是一位百科全书编纂者，不是吗？他不仅仅是一位百科全书编纂者。他是一位经验主义者。如果你想领悟动物王国的范围和广度，你实际上必须亲自动手。
think for Ptolemy, it's about, in a sense, preserving everything that is best about Greek culture. Well, also, he too has been educated by Aristotle because that's where he and Alexander had met. They'd studied together at wherever it was in that grove where Aristotle, they all gathered all the lads from the court, all the young lads. So absolutely, he must be influenced in the same way that Alexander was. Well, no, but I think you're absolutely right to mention Aristotle because I actually think that Aristotle, who as you say, has taught Ptolemy, is an absolutely key figure in this. Because Aristotle, after he has done his tutoring in Macedon, he goes back to Athens and he settles at a temple to Apollo called the Lyceum. This is quite well known as a place where philosophers go to talk. Socrates had gone
所以他似乎解剖了大象的胃来研究它。他切开了墨鱼。他著名地研究了印度人和埃塞俄比亚人的精液。为了发现正如希罗多德所说的那样，它是否是黑色的，他证明了它不是。所以从各个方面来看，都是亲身研究。我的意思是，证明这一点其实很容易，汤姆。你不需要做实验。我的意思是，无论如何，我们别谈这个了。而且亚里士多德也对世界各地不同的政治制度感兴趣。所以他汇编了一份伟大的词汇表，分析了所有不同的民主制、寡头制等等。
there and Plato had gone there. But Aristotle found something that is kind of more enduring and ambitious. So it's basically a kind of, I suppose, a research center, something like that. The reason that he needs a research center is because he's committed to this idea that to love wisdom, which is what philosophers by definition do, you have to train the mind in the skills that enable you to access the laws that govern the universe. And you can only do that over the course of an entire lifetime. So there needs to be a concentrated opportunity for philosophers to ponder and read and research and write and chat among their peers, because otherwise they're not
所以这就是正在发生的事情。他有各种各样的人在做这件事。吕克昂基本上是一个他们可以居住的综合体。所以有生活区，有一个公共餐厅，还有带柱廊的走道。在希腊语中是“peripatos”。这就是你在这种回廊里走来走去聊天的地方，有点像牛津或剑桥学院的回廊。去吕克昂并追随亚里士多德脚步的哲学家们被称为“逍遥学派”（Peripatetics）。问题是，这听起来可能像是一个当代现代的研究中心。在某种程度上确实如此，但它也是一个崇拜中心。它神圣地献给缪斯女神（Muses），即九位姐妹，她们是各种艺术、学术和文学学科的守护神。所以这个吕克昂，
adequately going to be able to fathom what makes the universe tick. So Plato, who we talked about in the context of Atlantis, Plato's great theory is that if you want to discern reality, reality lies beyond the, you know, there is an ideal, say, of a table. So if you want to know the essence of a table, that's what you have to access rather than kind of making a survey of every table that there is in existence. Aristotle has a slightly different perspective. He thinks you really do need to have a totalising sense of the entire world. He's an encyclopedist, isn't he? He's more than an encyclopedist. He's an empiricist. If you want to fathom the scope and sweep of the animal kingdom, you actually have to get your
这个亚里士多德建立的研究中心被称为“museon”，即缪斯神庙，英语化后就是“museum”（博物馆）。所以我认为这潜伏在背景中。现在，当你把这个想法移植到一个像亚历山大城这样巨大的城市时会发生什么？嗯，我们一直在谈论亚历山大城是多么的人造。它没有根基。以前，在像雅典或哲学开始的爱奥尼亚（Ionia）城市中，哲学家们借鉴了他们所属城市的文化和传统。但在亚历山大城，这些并不存在。更重要的是，马其顿对希腊世界的统治意味着这些传统处于轻微的停滞状态。它们处于深度冷冻状态。所以有各种各样的学者在四处漂泊，等待被一位富有的赞助人招募。当他们聚集在一起时，他们的视角不可避免地会是
hands dirty. So he slices open the stomach of an elephant, it seems, to investigate it. He cuts up cuttlefish. He famously, he seems to have investigated the semen of Indians and Ethiopians. To discover whether, as Herodotus has said, it was black, and he demonstrates that it wasn't. So in every sense, hands-on research. I mean, it's really quite easy to demonstrate that, Tom. You wouldn't need to do an experiment. I mean, whatever, let's not go there. And also Aristotle is interested in the range, of different political systems across the world. So he compiles a great kind of glossary, an analysis of all the different democracies and oligarchies and whatever.
世界主义的。而那种世界主义，完全是由亚历山大时代和他的征服所孕育的，我认为这就是大图书馆的本质。这就是图书馆所带来的东西。对。这一直让我着迷，因为当我写我自己关于克利奥帕特拉的《时间冒险》书时，我在图书馆里安排了她的一场戏。所以这些是给孩子们看的书，某种程度上让历史对孩子们鲜活起来。我在图书馆里安排了她的一场戏，因为我想为儿童读者描述图书馆，但我也想让克利奥帕特拉在里面读书。有趣的一点是，当我阅读所有关于克利奥帕特拉的书籍，那些学术书籍时，它们本身在
So this is what's going on. He's got all kinds of people who are doing this. And the Lyceum is basically a kind of complex where they can live. So there are living quarters, there's a kind of communal dining centre, and there are porticoed walkways. So it's a peripetos in Greek. It's where you kind of walk around this kind of cloister chatting away, a bit like the cloisters in an Oxford or Cambridge college. And the philosophers who go to the Lyceum and who follow in Aristotle's wakes are known as peripatetics after this. And the thing is that this may sound like a kind of contemporary modern day research center. And to a degree it is, but it is also a cult center. And it is sacred to the muses who are the nine sisters who are the patrons of all the various kind of arts and academic and literary disciplines. And so this Lyceum,
图书馆是否是博物馆（museum）或“museon”的一部分上存在分歧。实际上，他们并不确定“museon”到底是什么。所以你认为它是什么？好吧。我认为我们相当确定“museon”是什么，因为我们有相对详细的描述。由斯特拉博（Strabo）提供。来自奥古斯都（Augustus）时代，由一位叫斯特拉博的地理学家提供。是的。所以他说博物馆，“museon”，让我们称之为博物馆，是巨大的宫殿建筑群的一部分，即所谓的“Briceion”。所以它是托勒密人居住的这个巨大建筑群结构的一部分。是的。这是城市的一整个区域，宫殿建筑群。
this research center that Aristotle has established is known as a museon, a temple to the muses, which anglicized is museum. So that is lurking in the background, I think. Now, what happens when you transplant that idea to a city as immense as Alexandria? Well, we've been talking about how Alexandria is artificial. It has no roots. Previously, in a city like Athens or the cities in Ionia, where philosophy begins, the philosophers are drawing on the cultures and the traditions of the cities that they belong to. But in Alexandria, these don't exist. What is more, the Macedonian domination of the Greek world means that these traditions are slightly in abeyance. They're in deep freeze. So there are all these kind of scholars who are drifting around just waiting to be scooped up by a wealthy patron. And when they come together, their perspective inevitably is going to be
是的。它很大。斯特拉博说它拥有一个“peripatos”，也就是柱廊，就像雅典的吕克昂一样，它有一个柱廊大厅和一个餐厅，这两者吕克昂都有。在这个大厅里，博物馆的成员们聚在一起用餐，所以再次像牛津或剑桥学院的研究员一样，就像万灵学院（All Souls College），它以致力于研究而闻名，没有学生。是的。而且像万灵学院一样，你知道，令人愉快的环境，免费的食物，有人伺候你，你知道，你不需要自己做家务，汤姆。我认识一个人，他赢得了牛津大学万灵学院的奖学金。当他在那里时，他被告知作为最年轻的研究员，他的工作是负责
cosmopolitan. And that cosmopolitanism, which is absolutely bred of the age of Alexander and his conquests, that I think is the essence of the great library. That is what the library is bringing. Right. This has always fascinated me because when I was writing my own Adventures in Time book about Cleopatra, I had a scene with her in the library. So these are books for children, sort of bringing history alive for children. I had a scene with her in the library because I wanted to describe the library for child readers, but I also wanted to put Cleopatra in it reading a book. And one of the things that was interesting was when I was reading all the books about Cleopatra, the scholarly books, I mean, they themselves differ
在所有晚餐时提供葡萄酒。他的正式头衔，你敢相信吗，是“首席开瓶官”（Chief Screw）。对。所以我认为这很像托勒密人提供给……首席开瓶官。这些作为成员的知识分子……我怀疑在亚历山大城，那会有双重含义。人们反复强调你得到的食物和葡萄酒。而且那些没有在那里的人显然有一种嫉妒感。所以有一个叫弗利乌斯的提蒙（Timon of Phlius）的人对此发表了著名的讽刺评论，他显然没有被提供博物馆的奖学金，
on whether the library is part of the museum or the museon or not. And actually, they're not really certain what the museon is. So what do you think it is? Okay. I think we are pretty certain what the Museon is because we have a relatively detailed description of it. By Strabo. From the age of Augustus by, yes, a geographer called Strabo. Yeah. So he says that the museum, the Museon, let's call it the museum, is part of the great palace complex, the Briceion, as it was called. So it is part of the fabric of this enormous complex of buildings in which the Ptolemies live. Yeah. It's a whole quarter of the city, the palace complex.
他说在埃及这片土地上，人们用各种语言叽叽喳喳，许多人现在发现了一个养老院，作为皇家资助的文人，在缪斯女神的鸟笼里无休止地争吵。听起来很棒。是的。所以那种受补贴的学术和学术上的刻薄，对任何……嗯，任何听过我们奥本海默（Oppenheimer）播客的人来说，当奥本海默去
Yeah. It's huge. And Strabo says that it possesses a peripatos, so that's the colonnade, like the Lyceum had in Athens, that it has a columned hall and it has a dining hall, both of which the Lyceum had. And in in this hall the men who are the members of the museum they meet in common to dine so again rather like the fellows in a oxford or cambridge college like it's like all souls college which is famously dedicated to research and has no students yes um and like all souls you know the delightful surroundings free food people to wait on you hand and foot you know you don't have to do your own housework tom i knew somebody who uh won a prize fellowship to All Souls College Oxford. And when he was there, he was told his job as the most junior fellow was that he was in charge of
普林斯顿高等研究院（School of Advanced Study）工作，并无休止地为研讨室和T.S.艾略特（T.S. Eliot）的访问等事情争吵时，那正是那种感觉。完全正确。但我认为假设它完全像一个现代学院之类的东西是有风险的，因为有些元素提醒我们它在崇拜实践中的根源。
providing the wine at all the dinners. And his official title, would you believe, was the Chief Screw. Right. So that I think is pretty much the gig that is being offered by the Ptolemies to- Chief screw. These intellectuals who were members of- I suspect in Alexandria, that would have had a double meaning. There is repeatedly an emphasis on the food and the wine that you get. And there's definitely a sense of jealousy on the part of those who aren't there. So there's a celebrated satirical comment on it by a guy called Timon of Phlius, who clearly had not been offered a scholarship to the museum,
所以博物馆的负责人是由国王任命的祭司。从斯特拉博的描述来看，博物馆似乎与亚历山大的陵墓直接相连。所以就在它旁边，就在它旁边，不过可能是一个独立的建筑？我怀疑是同一个建筑群的一部分。模型可能实际上来自法老埃及，即拉美西斯二世（Ramesses II）的陵墓，希腊人对此非常非常感兴趣，它据说有一个崇拜中心。它有很多书，有一个陵墓，这一切都是同一个建筑群的一部分。所以这可能是它的一种直接灵感来源。
who says in the land of Egypt, where they jabber in a whole range of languages, many now find a rest home as royally funded hacks, endlessly quarreling in the birdcage of the muses. Sounds brilliant. Yeah. So that sense of kind of subsidized scholarship and academic bitchiness, it does seem familiar to anyone who's... Well, anyone who listened to our Oppenheimer podcast, when Oppenheimer went
但这里悬而未决的问题是，图书馆呢？因为斯特拉博没有提到图书馆。这就是谜题。现在，大多数学者，我认为，大体上都假设图书馆是与博物馆分开的建筑。绝对有一个首席图书馆员的职位，他同时也是王储的导师。绝对有一种感觉，这里有书。这一点毫无疑问。因此，问题是，这些书在哪里？我认为对此最令人信服的解释来自意大利学者卢西亚诺·坎福拉（Luciano Canfora）的一本书《消失的图书馆》（The Vanished Library），他认为，斯特拉博没有提到图书馆，原因很简单，卢西亚诺·坎福拉认为，斯特拉博没有提到图书馆，原因很简单，
to run the School of Advanced Study in Princeton and endlessly fighting about seminar rooms and visits by TS Eliot and stuff. That's exactly what that is. Exactly. But I think there is a risk in assuming that it is totally like a kind of modern college or something, because there are elements that remind us of its roots in cult practice.
因为它没有构成一个独立的房间或建筑。关于这一点，在《托勒密亚历山大》（Ptolemaic Alexandria）的作者、权威著作的作者P.M.弗雷泽（P.M. Fraser）给出的论点中有证据，他指出亚历山大图书馆，或者我应该正确地说亚历山大博物馆，在帕加马（Pergamum）激发了一个模仿的例子，那是现在土耳其的另一个首都。在那里，有足够的遗迹供考古学家重建平面图，那里没有独立的图书馆。所以这几乎可以肯定地意味着图书馆不是一个独立的建筑。我认为使这个论点如此令人信服的是，图书馆不是一个独立的建筑。我认为使这个论点如此令人信服的是，希腊语中图书馆的原始词汇实际上是存放书籍的书架。我认为这表明你拥有这种博物馆综合体，
So the man in charge of the museum is a priest appointed by the king. And it seems from Strabo's description that the museum is directly contiguous to the tomb of Alexander. So next to it, right next to it, it's a separate building though, probably? Part of the same complex, I suspect. It may be that the model for this is actually coming from Pharaonic Egypt, so the tomb of Ramesses II, which the Greeks were very, very interested in, which had supposedly a cult center. It had lots of books and had a tomb, and it was all part of the one complex. So it may be that that's a kind of direct inspiration for it.
你有书架，卷轴存放在书架上，它们是整个综合体结构的一部分。因此，后来被称为图书馆的东西是一个贯穿整个博物馆的特征。我喜欢那个论点，汤姆，但让我提出一个简短的反对意见。在我们开头提到的电子游戏《刺客信条：起源》中，为该游戏工作的学者们将设计基于一个现存的图书馆，我们知道它存在，它是最著名的罗马遗迹之一，即以弗所（Ephesus）的塞尔苏斯图书馆（Library of Celsus）。是的，那要晚得多。是的，所以那是在……什么时候？大约公元92年，所以那是罗马建筑，不是希腊建筑。是的，但我们因此知道，在罗马帝国的希腊语地区，在一个无疑会有的地区
But the question that is hanging here is, well, what about the library? Because Strabo does not mention the library. And this is the puzzle. Now, most scholars, I think, by and large, have assumed that the library is a separate building from the museum. There is definitely a post of chief librarian who is also tutor to the crown prince. There's definitely a sense that there are books here. There's no question about that. Therefore, the question is, where are these books? I think the most convincing explanation for this is in a book called The Vanished Library by the Italian scholar Luciano Canfora, who argues, Strabo does not mention the library for the simple reason Luciano Canfora, who argues Strabo does not mention the library for the simple reason that it did not constitute a separate room or building.
但这里悬而未决的问题是，图书馆呢？因为斯特拉博并没有提到图书馆。这就是谜团所在。现在，我认为大多数学者大体上都假设图书馆是与博物馆分开的建筑。确实有一个首席图书馆员的职位，他同时也是皇太子的导师。毫无疑问，这里确实有书。这一点毋庸置疑。因此，问题在于，这些书在哪里？我认为对此最有说服力的解释来自意大利学者卢西亚诺·坎福拉所著的《消失的图书馆》一书，他认为，斯特拉博没有提到图书馆的原因很简单，因为它并不构成一个独立的房间或建筑。
And there is evidence for this in the argument given by the author of Ptolemaic, Alexandria, P.M. Fraser, the great definitive volume on it, who points out that the library of Alexandria, or the museum of Alexandria, I should properly say, inspires a kind of copycat example in Pergamum, which is another capital in what's now Turkey. And there, there are sufficient remains for archaeologists to reconstruct the floor plan, and there is no separate library there. So that implies almost certainly that the library is not a separate building. And I think that what makes this such a convincing argument is that the library is not a separate building. I think that what makes this such a convincing argument is that the original word for library in Greek is actually the shelves on which books are kept. I think that what that suggests is that you have this kind of museum complex,
关于这一点，在《托勒密时代的亚历山大》一书的作者P.M.弗雷泽所给出的论点中可以找到证据，这是关于该主题的权威巨著。他指出，亚历山大图书馆，或者我应该更准确地说亚历山大博物馆，在帕加马激发了一种效仿的例子，帕加马是现在土耳其境内的另一个首都。在那里，考古学家有足够的遗迹来重建平面图，而且那里没有独立的图书馆。所以这几乎可以肯定地说明，图书馆不是一个独立的建筑。我认为这个论点之所以如此令人信服，是因为希腊语中图书馆的原始词汇实际上是指存放书籍的书架。我认为这表明你拥有的是这种博物馆综合体，
and you have shelves, and the scrolls are kept on the shelves, and they are part of the structure of the general complex. And that therefore, what comes to be called the library is a feature that is kind of running throughout the museum. I like that argument, Tom, but let me just raise one quick objection. In the video game that we mentioned at the beginning, Assassin's Creed Origins, the scholars who worked on that game based the design for it on an existing a library that we know existed very famous one of the most famous roman remains which is the library of celsus in ephesus yeah now that's quite a bit later it is so that's in the when's that uh about 92 a.d so that's a roman building not a greek building yeah but we know, therefore, that the Romans, in a Greek-speaking area of the Roman Empire, in an area that undoubtedly would have
你有书架，卷轴就存放在书架上，它们是整个综合体结构的一部分。因此，后来被称为图书馆的东西，实际上是贯穿整个博物馆的一个功能。汤姆，我喜欢这个论点，但让我提出一个简短的反对意见。在我们开头提到的电子游戏《刺客信条：起源》中，参与该游戏制作的学者们基于一个我们已知存在的图书馆来设计它，那是一个非常著名的罗马遗迹，即以弗所的塞尔苏斯图书馆。是的，那已经是相当晚期了。确实，那是大约公元92年，所以那是罗马建筑，而不是希腊建筑。是的，但我们因此知道，罗马人在罗马帝国讲希腊语的地区，在一个无疑会
had trade links with Alexandria, that there were separate libraries. There is a possibility, surely, given that so many records of Alexandria are lost, that they could have been a separate building. The Romans, a bit like American plutocrats in the Gilded Age, or indeed now, to be honest, they have the money and they are envious of the cultural prestige of the Greek world. And so they start amassing vast collections of books. And Egypt actually, because it's providing papyrus, becomes a great, great center of the book trade. Huge numbers of copies are made, are sent to Rome. The capital itself, of course, has the largest number of libraries, but you also have one in Herculaneum,
与亚历山大港有贸易往来，而且有独立的图书馆。考虑到亚历山大的许多记录都已遗失，它们完全有可能是独立的建筑，这当然是有可能的。罗马人有点像镀金时代的美国财阀，或者说实话，就像现在一样，他们有钱，而且嫉妒希腊世界的文化声望。于是他们开始积累大量的藏书。而埃及实际上因为提供纸莎草纸，成为了图书贸易的伟大中心。大量的副本被制作出来，并被送往罗马。当然，首都本身拥有最多的图书馆，但你在赫库兰尼姆也有一个，
very famously. There's a villa with all kinds of manuscripts that people dream ultimately of deciphering. So the Roman library is, I think, different from the kind of library that is being set up in the age of the first Ptolemies. More self-conscious in a way. It's more self-conscious. It's more self-aggrandizing. It's kind of nouveau riche. Right. Not that the Ptolemies weren't nouveau riche because of course they were. The Ptolemies are nouveau riche, but the Ptolemies are closer to, you know, they're Macedonians, so they're heirs to that tradition of cultural sponsorship that was practiced by the kings. And they are pretty much direct heirs to the traditions in Athens that Plato and Aristotle
非常出名。那里有一座别墅，里面有各种各样人们最终梦想破译的手稿。所以我认为，罗马的图书馆与第一批托勒密王朝时期建立的图书馆不同。在某种程度上更具自我意识。它更具自我意识。它更自大。它有点像暴发户。没错。并不是说托勒密王朝不是暴发户，因为他们当然是。托勒密王朝是暴发户，但托勒密王朝更接近，你知道，他们是马其顿人，所以他们是国王所实行的那种文化赞助传统的继承者。而且他们几乎是雅典柏拉图和亚里士多德传统的直接继承者
embody. So I think there is a difference there. And I think that the libraries that you get in both Imperial Rome and in the provinces, I think those libraries, by that point, the idea of a library is a distinct building that you construct essentially to show off how much learning you have. That can be done by individuals or it can be done on a civic basis. I think that that is something that is different from the Library of Alexandria. Okay. I can understand if in a computer game, you need to make it visible, They would be kind of a useful crutch, but I think that Camphora's argument is a better
所体现的。所以我认为这其中是有区别的。而且我认为你在帝国罗马和各省得到的图书馆，我认为在那个时候，图书馆的概念是一个独特的建筑，你建造它本质上是为了炫耀你拥有多少学识。这可以由个人完成，也可以在市政基础上完成。我认为这与亚历山大图书馆是不同的。好吧。我可以理解如果是在电脑游戏中，你需要让它可见，它们会是一种有用的拐杖，但我认为坎福拉的论点是一个更好
and more convincing one. Very good. Okay. So on that bombshell, we're going to take a break to consult our own collection. And when Tom has done his research, we'll return. So for you, I mean, Tom works so quickly. You'll probably just have time for one or two ads. And then you come back after the break. Yeah, come back after the break. And Tom is going to tell us what was in the library and how it was destroyed. Very exciting. See you after the break.
且更有说服力的论点。非常好。好的。带着这个重磅消息，我们要休息一下，去查阅我们自己的收藏。等汤姆做完他的研究，我们就会回来。对你来说，我的意思是，汤姆工作得太快了。你可能只有时间看一两个广告。然后休息后回来。是的，休息后回来。汤姆会告诉我们图书馆里有什么，以及它是如何被摧毁的。非常令人兴奋。休息后见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the Library of Alexandria. And Tom, the Library of Alexandria, I mean, people have this fantasy of it, don't they? It's the repository of all the world's wisdom. All kinds of scientific discoveries are happening, thanks to the books in the library. The scholars who are working in the museum are pushing the boundaries of knowledge. And then actually, there's this very common view, which you see repeated in popular histories and things, which is that with the loss of the Library of Alexandria, which was destroyed for reasons that we will go on to discuss, the world was
那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余谈》。我们现在在亚历山大图书馆。汤姆，亚历山大图书馆，我的意思是，人们对它有一种幻想，不是吗？它是世界所有智慧的宝库。多亏了图书馆里的书，各种科学发现正在发生。在博物馆工作的学者们正在拓展知识的边界。然后实际上，有一个非常普遍的观点，你在通俗历史等书籍中经常看到，那就是随着亚历山大图书馆的消失，它因我们将要讨论的原因而被摧毁，世界被
plunged into a darkness. The cause of science was set back. How much truth is there in this? And I can guess what your answer is going to be. Yeah. So there are two elements to that. There's the idea that the Library of Alexandria alone contains everything and therefore its loss cripples the world so much that we're plunged back into the dark ages. And that if that hadn't happened, then history would have been set on a far greater, smoother progress towards industrialization and spaceships and cures for cancer and all kinds of things like that. So this idea that the Library of Alexandria is a kind of scientific research center, that it's kind of MIT or Silicon Valley or something like that. Yeah, University of Wolverhampton.
陷入了黑暗。科学事业倒退了。这其中有多少真实性？我可以猜到你的答案会是什么。是的。所以这有两个要素。一个是认为仅亚历山大图书馆就包含了所有东西，因此它的损失使世界瘫痪，以至于我们陷入了黑暗时代。如果那没有发生，那么历史本会在通往工业化、宇宙飞船和癌症治疗等各种事物的道路上取得更大、更平稳的进步。所以这种认为亚历山大图书馆是一种科学研究中心，它有点像麻省理工学院或硅谷之类的想法。是的，伍尔弗汉普顿大学。
Not going that far. The truth about the Library of Alexandria is that its focus is overwhelmingly literary and Greek. So the scholars who are in the library seem to have seen as their mission essentially the rescue of the vast mass of Greek literature. They're doing this as people who have basically emancipated themselves from the city politics of classical Greece, and therefore have a sense of the entirety of the writings of Greece. They're anxious, I think, that amid all the wars that have plagued Greece for the past 200 years, the previous 200 years, there's every possibility that these texts will be lost. That's an absolutely kind of key part of it. This combines with the obsession of the Ptolemies for collecting.
没那么夸张。关于亚历山大图书馆的真相是，它的重点绝大多数是文学和希腊语。所以图书馆里的学者们似乎把拯救大量的希腊文学视为他们的使命。他们这样做是因为他们基本上已经从古典希腊的城市政治中解放出来，因此对希腊的全部著作有一种感觉。我认为他们很焦虑，因为在过去200年，即前200年困扰希腊的所有战争中，这些文本完全有可能丢失。这绝对是其中的一个关键部分。这与托勒密王朝对收藏的痴迷相结合。
Once you have the kind of ideal that you're going to get as many books as possible, that's tremendously fun if you're a king with very, very deep pockets. The Ptolemies are sending agents out across the Greek world, particularly to Athens, particularly to Rhodes, where they have the largest book markets. There are almost certainly apocryphal stories that Ptolemy III, who is the grandson of the first Ptolemy, that when ships dock in the harbor of Alexandria and if they're carrying books, the books will be removed. They'll be marked with the slogan, From the Ships, put into the library, copies made and given back to the disgruntled merchants. An even better story, which is almost certainly definitely not true, is that Ptolemy III wants
一旦你有了要尽可能多地获取书籍的理想，如果你是一个腰缠万贯的国王，那将是非常有趣的。托勒密王朝正在向整个希腊世界派遣代理人，特别是雅典，特别是罗德岛，那里有最大的图书市场。几乎可以肯定有伪经故事说，第三任托勒密，也就是第一任托勒密的孙子，当船只停靠在亚历山大港时，如果它们载有书籍，这些书就会被没收。它们会被标记上“来自船只”的口号，放入图书馆，制作副本并归还给不满的商人。一个更好的故事，几乎可以肯定绝对不是真的，是第三任托勒密想要
the original copies of the plays of the three greatest Athenian tragedians, Aeschylus, Sophocles, and Euripides. He asks the Athenians and the Athenians say no, and he keeps pestering them. Finally, the Athenians say, okay, but you'll have to pay an absolutely crippling deposit because we don't trust you. Ptolemy hands over the deposit and then just pockets the tragedies, and the Athenians are left with the deposit. This story develops clearly out of the sense that there is something faintly maniacal about the determination of the Ptolemies and librarians to get all these texts. And what they do then, having got all these texts, it seems, is basically to establish the definitive editions of pretty much all the classical texts that we have today. So your Homer's and Herodotus' and things. Absolutely. So you can measure this in the papyri that you find out in the deserts in Egypt, that from about 150 BC, so really once all the textual work has been done, you start getting
三位最伟大的雅典悲剧作家埃斯库罗斯、索福克勒斯和欧里庇得斯的原始剧本。他询问雅典人，雅典人说不，他一直纠缠他们。最后，雅典人说，好吧，但你必须支付一笔绝对沉重的押金，因为我们不信任你。托勒密交出了押金，然后就把悲剧据为己有，雅典人只剩下押金。这个故事显然源于这样一种感觉，即托勒密和图书管理员获取所有这些文本的决心有些近乎疯狂。然后他们所做的是，在得到所有这些文本后，似乎基本上是为我们今天拥有的几乎所有古典文本建立了权威版本。所以你的荷马和希罗多德之类的。绝对。所以你可以从你在埃及沙漠中发现的纸莎草纸中衡量这一点，从公元前150年左右开始，也就是一旦所有的文本工作都完成了，你就开始得到
standardized texts of the Iliad and the Odyssey that are the ancestors of the ones that students are using today. So that is a very, very great achievement. I mean, it's an absolutely astonishing achievement, but it's not perhaps on a level with curing cancer or building space rockets, which is really what I think people want to believe that was going on in the library. The truth is that there are amazing discoveries and breakthroughs at the library that are not to do with literature. So the classic example of this is the calculation to an astonishing degree of accuracy of the
《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》的标准文本，它们是学生今天使用的版本的祖先。所以这是一个非常非常伟大的成就。我的意思是，这是一个绝对令人震惊的成就，但它可能并不等同于治愈癌症或建造太空火箭，这确实是我认为人们想要相信在图书馆里发生的事情。事实是，图书馆里有惊人的发现和突破，与文学无关。所以这方面的经典例子是对比计算到惊人程度的
circumference of the earth, which is done by a scholar called Eratosthenes. And Eratosthenes essentially creates the mathematical foundations of geography and cartography. So the fact that you have all these texts, that you can consult them, and then you can put them together to construct maps of the world that are more accurate than any that had previously existed. Again, this is a fruit of the sense of a research institute that you have. Without this vast compendium of texts, that probably wouldn't have been possible. But it's really important to emphasize that for the Greeks, theory always triumphs over experiment. There's a line in Plato's Republic that I always think of in this context. Plato says, when we're looking at astronomy, we must approach it as we approach geometry by
地球周长，这是由一位名叫埃拉托色尼的学者完成的。埃拉托色尼基本上创造了地理学和制图学的数学基础。所以你拥有所有这些文本，你可以查阅它们，然后你可以把它们放在一起构建比以前存在的任何地图都更准确的世界地图。同样，这是你拥有的研究机构意识的果实。没有这本庞大的文本汇编，那可能是不可能的。但强调一点非常重要，对于希腊人来说，理论总是胜过实验。柏拉图的《理想国》中有一句话，我在这种背景下总是想到。柏拉图说，当我们观察天文学时，我们必须像对待几何学那样对待它，通过
way of working out problems and ignore what's in the sky. So in other words, the maths of astronomy is what really matters. The pinpricks of light in the sky, that's completely irrelevant. But all of that said, Tom, but all of that said, they do have coin-operated slot machines. They do have automatic doors. They do have... Have steam engines. Yeah, steam engines.
解决问题的方法，而忽略天空中有什么。换句话说，天文学的数学才是真正重要的。天空中那些针尖般的光点，那完全无关紧要。但话虽如此，汤姆，但话虽如此，他们确实有投币式自动售货机。他们确实有自动门。他们确实有……有蒸汽机。是的，蒸汽机。
Exactly. Practical inventions. But what they don't do is apply any of those to what we would recognize, say, as industrial policy. Yeah. You know, the steam engines are being used to power various gizmos and temples. Yeah. They're not being used to power railway trains that can be
没错。实用的发明。但他们没有做的是将其中任何一个应用到我们所认识的，比如说，工业政策上。是的。你知道，蒸汽机被用来驱动各种小玩意和寺庙。是的。它们没有被用来驱动可以在沙漠上铺设去攻击敌人的火车之类的东西。不。那些托勒密装甲列车本来会很棒的。所以阿诺德·汤因比很有名，这是他的假设之一，即亚历山大图书馆在技术上是有头脑的。他显然是在写这篇文章时想到了当时的大英帝国远征。亚历山大图书馆不是一个伟大的技术中心。那不是它的意义所在。而且我认为另一个神话是它是普遍的，在渴望包含世界所有智慧的意义上。真的，它的重点是希腊的。我们有这种想法的原因是它
laid out over the desert to go and attack enemies or anything like that. No. Those Ptolemaic armoured trains would have been brilliant though. So Arnold Toynbee famously, this was one of his what-ifs that the Library of Alexandria had actually been technically minded. And he's obviously kind of thinking of imperial British expeditions at the time when he was writing it. The Library of Alexandria is not a great centre of technology. That is not what it's about. And I think the other myth is that it is universal in the sense of aspiring to contain all the wisdom of the world. Really, its focus is Greek. The reason that we have this idea that it
可能是普遍的，是因为一个非常著名的神话，即据说第二任托勒密想要了解犹太人的经文。有很多犹太人在亚历山大定居。他们是人口中相当大的一部分。故事是说第二任托勒密派人去耶路撒冷寻找能将希伯来经文翻译成希腊语的人。他派了72名学者，以色列12个部落中每个部落6人。他们被安置在法罗斯岛，也就是有灯塔的岛上，他们为皇家图书馆提出了一个希腊语翻译。这就是《七十士译本》，将希伯来经文翻译成希腊语。《七十士译本》来自拉丁语的70，所以它是从72向下取整的。但正如我所说，这是一个神话。它包含在一封据称由一个名叫
might have been universal is because of a very famous myth, which is that Ptolemy II, it is said, wants to know the scriptures of the Jews. There are lots of Jews that have been settled in Alexandria. They are a sizable part of the population. The story goes that Ptolemy II sends to Jerusalem for people who can translate the Hebrew scriptures into Greek. He has sent 72 scholars, six from each of the 12 tribes of Israel. They are put up on the Pharos, the island with the lighthouse, and they come up with a Greek translation for the royal library. This is the Septuagint, the translation of Hebrew scripture into Greek. Septuagint comes from the Latin for 70, so it's a rounding down from the 72. But this is, as I say, a myth. It's contained in a letter supposedly written by a guy called
阿里斯提亚斯在公元前2世纪写的人写的信中，所以距离它本应发生的时间已经很久了。本质上，它是在为犹太人成为亚历山大希腊文化的一部分辩护。亚历山大存在长期的反犹太主义。他正在向希腊人推销，说，看，我们的学识是人类知识普遍语料库的一部分。托勒密王朝对它感兴趣。它已经进入了博物馆，进入了图书馆，但其意图是非常明显的。但还有一个反驳论点。这是一个不寻常的立场，因为你在这里非常像修正主义者，而我坚持对图书馆的正统解释，更浪漫的解释，我会说它在，这通常你是《历史余谈》中更浪漫的主持人。所以克利奥帕特拉，我们被告知，我想，
Aristas in the 2nd century BC, so long after it's meant to have happened. Essentially, it's making a case for the Jews to be a part of Hellenic culture in Alexandria. There's chronic antisemitism in Alexandria. He's making a pitch to the Greeks to say, look, our learning is a part of the universal corpus of human knowledge. The Ptolemies are interested in it. It's gone into the museum, into the library, but the intention of that is very palpable. But one more counter-argument. This is an unusual position because you're very much the revisionist here, and I'm sticking up for the orthodox interpretation of the library, the more romantic one, I would say it's on, which is usually you're the more romantic presenter of the rest of this history. So Cleopatra, we're told, I think,
普鲁塔克说克利奥帕特拉会说希腊语、埃及语、埃塞俄比亚语、阿拉姆语、叙利亚语、米底语、帕提亚语、一种阿拉伯语和穴居人的语言。这难道不说明在……的核心有一种普遍主义、一种多元文化主义吗？因为如果她确实会说这些语言中的任何一种，她大概至少会从在博物馆和图书馆工作的学者那里学到其中一些。不，因为克利奥帕特拉是著名的第一位会说埃及语的托勒密。没错。但也许那是因为埃及语被认为比其他一些语言等级更低。这并不意味着没有巨大的语言漩涡。嗯，我认为以我们的眼光来看，托勒密王朝在统治埃及的这么多代人中竟然不会说埃及语，这令人震惊。但弗利乌斯的蒂蒙，你在上半部分提到的，在埃及这片土地上，他们叽里呱啦地说着各种
by Plutarch that Cleopatra spoke Greek, Egyptian, Ethiopian, Aramaic, Syriac, Median, Parthian, an Arabic language, and the language of the Troglodytes. Doesn't that speak to a kind of universalism, a multiculturalism at the heart of the – because presumably if she did speak any of these languages, she would have learned at least some of them from the scholars working in the museum and the library. No, because Cleopatra is famously the first of the Ptolemies to speak Egyptian. Right. But maybe that's because Egyptian is regarded as a lower level than some of the others. It doesn't mean that there isn't a great swirl of language. Well, I think by our lights, it's astounding that the Ptolemies over all these generations that they've been ruling Egypt don't learn to speak Egyptian. But Timon of Phlius, you had in the first half, in the land of Egypt where they jabber in a whole
范围的语言，他说。所以这片土地上确实有一种多元文化主义。一定有。不，因为他在否定它。他说那甚至不是希腊语。埃及的大多数人说某种，你知道，某种野蛮的语言，我的意思是这就是野蛮人的意思，是一个不会说希腊语的人，但是那里的暗示不是说一些他专门谈论学者，一些学者也许他们都在说希腊语，但他们来自不同的地方，有一种交流吗？是的，但他们都是说希腊语的，他们只对希腊语感兴趣。他们对其他任何东西都不感兴趣。好吧。嗯，我想，这在我们看来绝不可能等同于普遍，但对希腊人来说确实如此。例如，你会注意到克利奥帕特拉不会说拉丁语，考虑到她的两个男朋友都是罗马人，这很神奇。
range of languages, he said. So there is a kind of multiculturalism there in the land. There must be. No, because he's dismissing it. He's saying it's not even Greek. most of the people in egypt speak some you know some barbarous language i mean that's what barbarian is it's someone who doesn't speak greek who goes but isn't the implication there that some of the he's talking about the scholars specifically that some of the scholars that maybe they are all speaking greek but they're coming from different places and there is a kind of exchange yeah but they're all greek speaking they're only interested in Greek. They're not interested in anything else. Okay. Well, I think, which to our way of thinking can't possibly equate to universal, but to the Greeks it does. For instance, you will note that Cleopatra isn't speaking Latin, which is amazing considering that her two boyfriends are both Roman.
她是怎么跟他们说话的，汤姆？他们都会说希腊语吗？是的。因为有一种假设认为希腊语是你在这段时期在地中海各地唯一需要掌握的语言。嗯，我想这就是重点，不是吗？希腊语被认为是这一时期地中海各地的学习和文化语言。是的。所以基本上，我认为亚历山大图书馆并不像人们想象的那么普遍。所以这本质上是一个神话。另一个大问题是它发生了什么？它去哪了？这通常被框定为谁摧毁了它。假设是有人或某种巨大的毁灭性火灾摧毁了图书馆。所以一个受欢迎的候选人，正如你所知，多米尼克，因为你在关于克利奥帕特拉的书里写过它，是尤利乌斯·凯撒。你被说服了吗？
How did she speak to them, Tom? Do they both speak Greek? Yes. Because there is assumption that Greek is the only language that you need. Well, I suppose that's the thing, isn't it? That Greek is perceived as being the language of learning and of culture across the Mediterranean in this period. Yeah. So basically, I think that the Library of Alexandra isn't nearly as universal as people think. So that essentially is one myth. The other great question is what happens to it? Where does it go? And that is usually framed as who destroys it. The assumption is that someone or some kind of great sweeping catastrophe of fire has wiped the library out. So a favorite candidate, as you'll know, Dominic, because you write about it in your book on Cleopatra, is Julius Caesar. Are you convinced by that?
不。凯撒引起了一场火灾。毫无疑问。当他被困在亚历山大港时，作为他对抗庞培战争的一部分访问了埃及，他安置了自己。他占领了宫殿区。他最终和克利奥帕特拉住在一起。他在和她的兄弟打仗，不是吗？托勒密。是的，当然，他们都叫托勒密。在这个过程中，港口发生了一场大战斗，凯撒，如果你相信这些记录的话，似乎放火烧了自己的船以阻止敌人夺取它们，在这个过程中，火势从船只蔓延到仓库，那里的书被损坏了，但我的意思是，正如你所知，汤姆，图书馆不在
No. Caesar causes a fire. There's no doubt about that. When he's trapped in Alexandria, having visited Egypt as part of his war against Pompey, he's installed himself. He's taken possession of the palace quarter. He ends up being shacked up with Cleopatra. He's fighting against her brother, isn't he? Ptolemy. Yeah, of course, they're all called Ptolemy. And the course of this there is a big fight down at the harbour and Caesar it seems if you're to believe the accounts sets fire to his own ships to stop the enemy getting hold of them and in the course of that the fire spreads from the ships to the warehouses and the books there are damaged but I mean as as you will know Tom the library is not at
码头，所以火势蔓延是可以想象的，但它必须蔓延很长一段距离。你怎么看？困惑是由普鲁塔克引起的，他确实说图书馆在这场火灾中被摧毁了。我们确实知道他从哪里得到的，因为很明显大量的书籍被摧毁了。这记录在许多来源中，所有这些似乎都追溯到李维，他是伟大的罗马历史学家，在奥古斯都统治时期，即尤利乌斯·凯撒去世后不久写作。他说有存放谷物和书籍的仓库。另一个似乎源自李维的细节是，4万卷书偶然存放在那里。
the docks so it's conceivable the fire spread, but it would have had to spread a hell of a long way. What do you think about it? The confusion is caused by Plutarch, who does say the library is destroyed in this fire. We do know where he gets it from because it's evident that large quantities of books were destroyed. This is recorded in a number of sources, all of which seem to go back to Livy, who is the great Roman historian who's writing shortly after the lifetime of Julius Caesar in the reign of Augustus. And he says that there are warehouses that contain grain and books. Another detail that seems to derive from Livy is that 40,000 scrolls were stored there by chance.
所以那个“偶然”是至关重要的，因为它说它们不是作为永久收藏的一部分在那里。它们碰巧在那里。为什么它们会碰巧在那里？嗯，我们之前谈到了这种巨大的图书贸易，把书、把卷轴带到罗马和意大利，带到罗马世界的伟大财阀那里。可能这就是原因。嗯，你自己也说了，埃及是纸莎草纸的伟大出口国。是的，绝对。我认为我们有相当确凿的证据表明，图书馆，无论它是什么，无论是博物馆的一部分还是独立的东西，在多米提安统治时期，也就是公元一世纪末，仍然存在，因为苏维托尼乌斯，他正在描述一场席卷罗马的火灾，在多米提安统治时期，以及多米提安如何
So that by chance is crucial because it's saying they're not there as part of a permanent collection. They happen to be there. And why would they happen to be there? Well, we talked earlier about this great trade in books, taking books, taking scrolls to Rome and to Italy and to the great plutocrats of the Roman world. And probably that's what this is. Well, you said yourself, Egypt is a great exporter of papyrus. Yeah, absolutely. I think we have pretty conclusive proof that the library, whatever it was, whether it was part of the museum or whether it was something separate, was still in existence in the reign of Domitian, who is end of the first century AD, because Suetonius, he's describing a fire that sweeps Rome in Domitian's reign and how Domitian
派遣抄写员去亚历山大港制作在罗马图书馆中丢失的文本的副本。所以有一种感觉，亚历山大港仍然是你会去的伟大文本仓库。那么问题来了，如果不是尤利乌斯·凯撒，那是什么时候？事实是，在三世纪和四世纪的过程中，当罗马世界被内战和各种灾难蹂躏时，有无数的灾难可能摧毁了博物馆和图书馆。在三世纪初，卡拉卡拉统治下有一场巨大的毁灭循环。奥勒良，他是那个在三世纪中期帝国似乎正在瓦解时将其重新缝合在一起的皇帝。而且明确指出，布鲁塞翁，也就是所有宫殿所在的区域，奥勒良摧毁了它。所以如果他摧毁了宫殿，那么他也一定摧毁了博物馆。然后我们被告知在三世纪末戴克里先统治时期还有另一场毁灭循环。所以我认为，到四世纪末还有任何残余的可能性微乎其微。不仅因为，汤姆，亚历山大港不仅是一座拥有巨大复杂性和文化等的城市，而且它作为一座暴民暴力、骚乱的城市而臭名昭著。亚历山大人以倾向于公民混乱而闻名，他们总是烧毁城市的一部分，砸碎东西。所以很难想象在那个
sends scribes to Alexandria to make copies of the texts that haveeps Rome in Domitian's reign and how Domitian sends scribes to Alexandria to make copies of the texts that have been lost in the libraries in Rome. So there's this sense that Alexandria remains the great depository of texts where you would go. So then the question, well, if not Julius Caesar, then when? And the fact is that over the course of the third century and into the fourth, when the Roman world is ravaged by civil war and all kinds of catastrophes, there are any number of disasters that might have destroyed the museum and the library. There's a great cycle of destruction under Caracalla at the beginning of the third century. Aurelian, who is the emperor who kind of stitches the empire back together after it seems to be disintegrating in the mid
从托勒密王朝结束一直到四世纪的中间时期，考虑到他们总是发生这些骚乱和暴动，图书馆能毫发无损地幸存下来。没错。除了最著名的暴民暴力例子实际上发生在391年。所以那几乎是君士坦丁皈依基督教一个世纪之后。当时一群基督教暴徒转向了塞拉皮斯大神庙，这是一个融合的人造神，基本上是由托勒密王朝发明的，试图为他们的希腊和埃及臣民提供一个焦点。
third century. And it's specified that the bruceon, which is the area with all the palace, that Aurelian had destroyed it. So if he's destroyed the palace, then he must have destroyed the museum as well. And then we're told that there was another cycle of destruction in the reign of Diocletian at the end of the third century. So I would say that the odds on anything remaining of it by the end of the fourth century would be minimal. Not least because, Tom, Alexandria is not just a city of tremendous sophistication and culture and so on, but it is notorious as a city of mob violence, of rioting. The Alexandrians are famously given to civic disorder and they're always burning down bits of their city, smashing things up. So it's hard to imagine that in that
但这是一种非常宏大、令人印象深刻的建筑。任何看过蕾切尔·薇兹主演的电影《城市广场》的人，它就是其中的核心。它做得非常出色。理论是里面有一个图书馆，这是主亚历山大图书馆的一部分、细分或竞争对手，而这群基督教暴徒袭击了塞拉皮斯，《罗马帝国衰亡史》的作者，他有，我的意思是，他有自己的理由把基督徒描绘成偏执狂，而且——嗯，他们是他书中的反派。所以他写道，亚历山大的宝贵图书馆被掠夺或摧毁，20年后，空书架的出现引起了每一个思想没有被宗教偏见完全遮蔽的观众的遗憾和愤慨。所以认为书会被摧毁，但书架
intervening period of time, from the end of the Ptolemies all the way through to the fourth century, that the library would have survived utterly unscathed given that they're always having these ruckuses and riots. Right. Except that the most famous example of mob violence actually happens in 391. So that is almost a century after Constantine's conversion to Christianity. And it is when a Christian mob turns on the great temple of Serapis, who is this syncretic artificial deity who'd basically been invented by the Ptolemies to try and provide a focus for both their Greek and Egyptian subjects.
留下来，我的意思是，这显然吉本是在想博德利图书馆的书架被剥离，我想。这只是一个在今天的作家中非常流行的想法。我想，例如，几年前的书，凯瑟琳·尼克西的《黑暗时代》，她基本上认为古典世界的所有这些巨大知识都被基督徒摧毁了，基督教应对将世界陷入她所称的黑暗时代负责。关于这一点，我们有关于塞拉皮斯神庙被毁的五份记录。所以它是亚历山大整个历史上记录最详尽的事件之一，但没有一份提到
But this is a very kind of vast, impressive building. Anyone who's seen the film Agora with Rachel Weisz, it's the centerpiece of that. It's brilliantly well done. And the theory is that there was a library in there that this was either a part of or a subdivision or a rival to the main library of Alexandria, and that this Christian mob attacked the Ser author of The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire, who has, I mean, he has his own reasons to present Christians as bigots and- Well, they're the villains of his book. So he writes, the valuable library of Alexandria was pillaged or destroyed, and 20 years afterwards, the appearance of the empty shelves excited the regret and indignation of every spectator whose mind was not totally darkened by religious prejudice. So the idea that the books would be destroyed, but the shelves
图书馆的毁灭。而且在古典文本幸存下来的程度上，这归功于基督教抄写员、基督教文士的努力。没有他们，我们将一无所有。所以我不认为基督徒做了这件事，我也绝对不认为穆斯林做了这件事，但他们也被指为罪魁祸首。是的，互联网上有很多东西说他们是故事里的坏人。没错。所以这更不可能。但故事是阿拉伯人横扫埃及，他们征服了它，他们围攻亚历山大港，他们占领了它。阿拉伯人的指挥官阿姆鲁写信给哈里发奥马尔，说，嗯，你拥有这座伟大的城市，有一个巨大的图书馆，里面装满了书，我们该怎么处理它们？他等待着，然后奥马尔的回复来了。
left, I mean, it's obviously Gibbon is thinking of the shelves of the Bodleian being stripped, I think there. And that's just an idea that is immensely popular today among writers. I think of it, for example, of the few years ago, the book, The Darkening Age by Catherine Nixie, where she basically argued all this tremendous learning of the classical world was destroyed by the Christians, that Christianity was responsible for plunging the world into a darkening age, as she calls it. On that, we have five accounts of the destruction of the Serapaeum. So it is one of the best authenticated episodes in the whole history of Alexandria, but none of them mention the
如果你提到的书的内容符合安拉之书，我们可能不需要它们，因为在这种情况下，安拉之书绰绰有余。另一方面，如果它们包含不符合安拉之书的内容，就没有必要保留它们。那就继续摧毁它们吧。我们不需要其他的书。是的。我的意思是，这显然不是真的。同样，穆斯林对希腊哲学的遗产有巨大的尊重。这之所以能幸存下来，是因为它在某种程度上符合那些对制度化宗教非常敌视的人喜欢想象的那样。当然。那些除了自己的圣书之外没有时间做任何事情的偏执狂。是的。对制度化宗教敌视的人喜欢想象的那样。
destruction of a library. And to the degree that classical texts have survived, it's down to the efforts of Christian copyists, Christian scribes. Without them, we would have nothing. So I don't think the Christians did it, and I definitely don't think the Muslims did it, but they also have been fingered as culprits. Yeah, there's lots of stuff on the internet saying that they're the bad guys in the story. Right. So this is even more improbable. But the story is that the Arabs sweep into Egypt, they conquer it, they lay siege to Alexandria, they capture it. The commander of the Arabs, Amr, writes to Omar, the caliph, and says, well, you've got all this great city, there's this enormous library, it's full of books, what should we do with them? And he waits, and then Omar's reply comes back.
当然。你知道，那些除了自己的圣书之外没有时间做任何事情的偏执狂。是的。这实际上是一种启蒙神话。所以你认为认为图书馆被摧毁的那一刻是18世纪的产物，一个幻想，一个投射，我想。而实际上发生的是图书馆可能部分被废弃了。其中一些部分可能在火灾中被烧毁，谁知道呢？
If the content of the books you mention is in accordance with the Book of Allah, we may do without them, for in that case, the Book of Allah more than suffices. If, on the other hand, they contain matter not in accordance with the Book of Allah, there can be no need to preserve them. Proceed then and destroy them. We have no need of other books. Yeah. I mean, it's so clearly not true. Again, the Muslims had huge respect for the legacy of Greek philosophy. The reason that this survives is that it's kind of in accordance with what people who are very hostile to institutional religion like to imagine about it. Of course. That it's all bigots who have no time for anything other than their own holy books. Yeah. hostile to institutional religion like to imagine about it.
而实际上只是收藏被拆分了，谁知道呢？那甚至不是一个事件，而是一个没人注意到的缓慢过程。是的。我认为存在一个黑暗时代的想法，你想，嗯，为什么会有黑暗时代？如果你能把它归咎于，比如说，单一巨大知识宝库被火摧毁，那会更戏剧性。但实际上，就在这一集的开头，我们谈到了与火烧后能幸存的泥板不同，纸莎草纸极其脆弱。你实际上不需要火来摧毁它。如果你把所有这些卷轴放在里面，它们没有空调，它们没有温度检查，它们有老鼠，
Of course. You know, that it's all bigots who have no time for anything other than their own holy books. Yeah. It's a kind of enlightenment myth, really. So do you think the idea that there was one single moment when the library was destroyed is simply a product of the 18th century, a fantasy, a projection, I suppose. And that actually what happened was that the library probably fell partly into disuse. Bits of it were perhaps burned in fires, who knows?
它们会碎掉。当你阅读它们时，它们会碎掉。绝对。除非这些文本被不断地重写、重写、重写，否则它们会消失。我的意思是，我们被告知宫殿建筑群的建筑被奥勒良摧毁了。我的意思是，也许那是它的最终终点，但我怀疑大多数文本在那之前很久很久就已经消失了。而且实际上，对此评论最精彩的人是吉本，他除了是各种启蒙运动神话的热衷者之外，还是一位杰出的、杰出的学者，他研究并调查了所有可用的来源，以获取他正在讲述的叙事。
And that actually just the collection was split up and who knows? It wasn't even an event actually, but a slow process that nobody even noticed. Yeah. I think the idea of there being a dark age, you want to think, well, why was there a dark age? And it's much more dramatic if you can blame it, say, on the destruction by fire of a single vast repository of learning. But actually, right at the beginning of this episode, we talked about how unlike clay tablets, which survive when they're fired, papyrus is incredibly fragile. You don't actually need a fire to destroy it. If you're keeping all these scrolls in, they're not air conditioned, they're not temperature checked, they're a mice,
他写道，我真诚地遗憾那些卷入罗马帝国毁灭的更有价值的图书馆，但当我认真计算岁月的流逝、无知的浪费和战争的灾难时，我们的宝藏，而不是我们的损失，才是让我惊讶的对象。所以不要哀悼我们失去的，而要庆祝我们保留的。我的意思是，那实际上是一个相当不错的消息，不是吗？是的。非常不吉本，考虑到他通常如此怀疑，如此……嗯，不，我认为《衰亡史》是对那里存在的文本数量的伟大纪念。
they crumble away. They crumble when you're reading them. Absolutely. Unless those texts are being rewritten and rewritten and rewritten, they're going to fall away. I mean, we're told that the buildings of the palace complex are destroyed by Aurelian. I mean, maybe that is the final terminus for it, but I suspect that most of the texts had already gone long, long before that. And actually, the person who comments most wonderfully on this is Gibbon, who, as well as being an enthusiast for various enlightenment-enthused myths, is a brilliant, brilliant scholar who has studied and investigated all the available sources for the narratives that
我想吉本，这就是他所表达的。感谢上帝，我不必再读更多的书了。这就是他在想的。但再次重复我们开头所说的，我认为亚历山大图书馆不再存在的事实正是赋予它作为图书馆神话象征的力量的原因。多棒的故事啊，汤姆。我真的很喜欢。而且实际上，这激发了我两件事。一是亚历山大城实际上会是一个很棒的故事，在《历史余谈》中做，亚历山大的兴衰。还有托勒密王朝，托勒密王朝，希腊化世界。我们还没有真正做太多关于他们的内容。我们做了克利奥帕特拉，
he's telling. He writes that, I sincerely regret the more valuable libraries which have been involved in the ruin of the Roman Empire, but when I seriously compute the lapse of ages, the waste of ignorance, and the calamities of war, our treasures, rather than our losses, are the object of my surprise. So don't mourn what we've lost, but celebrate what we've retained. I mean, that's actually quite a nice message, isn't it? Yeah. Very un-Gibbonian, given that he's normally so sceptical and so sort of… Well, no, I think the decline and fall is a great monument to the amount of texts that are there.
但我喜欢托勒密王朝的故事。这非常复杂，因为他们总是互相结婚，不是吗？而且他们都叫托勒密。而且他们都叫托勒密，这可能是一个问题。但他们有有趣的绰号，我们可以——是的。第八任的儿子，胖子。是的，托勒密。是的。他娶了他的妹妹。是的。同时娶了他的妹妹和侄女。
And I guess that Gibbon, that's what he is expressing. Thank God I don't have to do any more reading. That's what he's thinking. But to repeat, again, what we said at the beginning, I think the fact that the Library of Alexandria is no longer there is precisely what gives it its potency as a kind of mythic symbol of libraries. What a wonderful story, Tom. I really enjoyed that. And actually, that's fired me up for two things. One is the city of Alexandria would be a fantastic story, actually, to do in the rest of history, the rise and fall of Alexandria. But also the Ptolemies, the Ptolemaic dynasty, the Hellenistic world. We haven't really done much about them. We did Cleopatra,
伟大的东西。精彩的行为。是的。好的。带着这个重磅消息，非常感谢你，汤姆。那真的很有趣。你想再宣传一下你的图书馆吗？大英图书馆，是的。它的50岁生日。图书馆里有各种各样的展览和特别节目。
but I love the story of the Ptolemies. It's very complicated because they're always marrying each other, aren't they? And they're all called Ptolemy. And they're all called Ptolemy, which might be an issue. But they have amusing nicknames, which we could- Yeah. The son of the eighth, Fatty. Yeah, Ptolemy. Yes. He married his sister. Yeah. Sister and his niece at the same time.
所以如果你在伦敦并且有机会去体验它们，请务必去。基本上，为图书馆欢呼。是的。因为没有它们，我们就无法制作这个播客。不，不。特别是博德利图书馆。好的。下次见，大家。再见。再见。
Great stuff. Fantastic behavior. Yeah. Right. On that bombshell, thank you so much for that, Tom. That was really good fun. And do you want to plug your library again? British Library, yes. It's 50th birthday. All kinds of exhibitions and specials on at the library.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
So if you're in London and have a chance to go and sample them, please do. And hurrah for libraries, basically. Yeah. Because without them, we wouldn't be able to do this podcast. No, no. Especially the Bodleian Library. Right. We'll see you all next time, everybody. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
所以如果你在伦敦，有机会去体验一下，请务必去看看。总之，为图书馆欢呼吧。是的。因为没有它们，我们就无法制作这个播客。没错，没错。尤其是博德利图书馆。好的。下次再见，各位。再见。再见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。